Busy hey mom
Do you guys remember when you told me if I got perfect grades all the way through middle school?
I could have anything I wanted I think it was to war up any further talk of a pony
Well, I know what it is. I don't know do we family trip to Antigua?
Ponies are cute and maybe not as much trouble as we thought
I was taken by her beauty and talent
I'm accompanying the first graders. That's a big deal be gonna come. No, you wouldn't like it. The words are way too cute
You might die as cuteness. Yeah. Well, I wanna die of cuteness. It's my favorite thing to die acuteness
Something unexpected has come up it has much more explanation coming but I have this one shot
Just thinking about us got my heart racing
Bernadette
You'll never guess what happened she disappeared Bernadette what she didn't just vanish
I'm gonna get my gear
Right that burn it up Bernadette